the record number of new covet cases and
controversy over the cdc's coveted
response we'll hear from the cdc's
director in just a few minutes more than
400 000 cases were reported yesterday
across the united states the most ever
in one day our country is averaging more
than 240 000 new cases a day over the
last week mark strossman is outside cdc
headquarters in atlanta a day after new
guidance was announced for people who
test positive mark good morning
good morning vlad once again the cdc is
under fire its critics are frustrated
confused angry about this latest
guidance which cuts by half the number
of days infected people have to
quarantine from ten to five and as soon
as they show no symptoms the cdc says
they're ready to rejoin everyone else
are you feeling okay today dear critics
call it reckless the cdc's new end of
quarantine guidance says nothing about
passing a covid test first if you can
find one you can't get an appointment
anywhere else so after the new year the
omicron variant continues to disrupt
almost every aspect of american life on
tuesday alone the airlines had to cancel
more than one thousand flights
in san diego covid forced ucla's
football team to pull out from tuesday's
holiday bowl while the nfl set a new
record for the number of players out
with covid 106 added to the reserve list
businesses like atlanta's ticonderoga
club are running out of employees and
options we have people testing 10 days
later still testing positive and it's
like well
that doesn't make us feel very confident
the cdc's new guidance on emerging from
covet isolation could ease those
widespread workphase disruptions
shortening the isolation window for
covett patients showing no symptoms from
10 days to just five but without first
passing a cova test critics say those
people unknowingly could pour gas on
america's wildfire of covid if you save
five days but send somebody back
infectious and they infect three people
and they also come back and infect
another three people each you know very
quickly of balloons
here in atlanta the news party is over
before it ever began canceled because of
covid for the second year in a row from
new york to los angeles to major cities
around the world new year's celebrations
have either been canceled or
significantly cut back
nate
mark thank you